Ernest how confident are you in the
ability of the Iran deal to contain
Iran's nuclear threat I'm quite
confident yeah and you worked a lot on
that right indeed yeah and the reason is
something that has seldom talked about
the deal puts in place verification
measures that are completely unique and
apply to this deal forever Donald Trump
said it's maybe the worst deal in
history of the world because everything
he thinks of this the worst in the
history of the world but so is it this
is another case where he found out more
I love the fact that information would
help you've got it the Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson yeah saying that
that so far Iran has been compliant with
the deal it in on the same day you got
Trump saying we got to get rid of it it
is I mean it is amazing the way like I
said the monologue they start off with
nobody knew and they come back to boy I
guess what Obama was doing is actually
the best you know there's no great
answer is no great answers out there
again cannot you I ad we see what
happens when you don't get in early
enough and let's say not North not
getting North Korea stopped yeah before
they have a nuclear problem though is
that with North Korea you you don't have
as many players that you were able to
put together the Obama administration
put their together a great coalition to
put pressure on Iran right now we
basically only have China yeah and that
that's all we have to put pressure on on
North Korea so that's a sole Chuck
Traynor
Tyron do you think more sexism exists on
one side of the aisle or is it a
bipartisan problem well obviously it's
somewhat bipartisan we know Clinton and
then Sarah but did you ever work at Fox
News which I do not have ever been
called hot chocolate hell I would
actually probably be called like mocha
mocha macchiato or something given why
not chocolate but no not at Fox News
anyway but I have appeared there and I
had appeared on on Bill O'Reilly show
years passed and I hadn't experienced
that but I do have friends that have
been over there and you know there was a
very problematic culture obviously but I
think it also is a reflection of the
generation of the people who ran it you
know when you look at guys that are at
that age
rushon the madman jensen but yeah i mean
that would they come from a time where
located you have to slap a just about no
i mean i guess okay prejudice yeah oh
yes you were I think it's okay I'm
saying that it no weapon but you're
elected you ask the question well I know
but your accident I feel like and I'm
saying that what happened at FoxNews is
an example of a generation where that
was okay and now when you see the way
that you resulted it the generation now
is saying like that's not okay we've
seen a lot of advances and so I think
you're going to see less and less of
this kind of overt sexism it's not oh
it's not over with but you know there's
progress is being made you see that
people are paying a price for it okay
Nick do you think there are Nick
President Trump spoke at the NRA today
yes do you think there are avenues to
make progress on gun control yeah I mean
and I'm deeply involved in that issue
and there's a tremendous amount of
opportunity to make progress on gun
violence prevention in cities and states
around the country and the only way that
we will make progress on those issues is
in cities and states and we passed
background checks in Washington state we
PACs passed extreme risk protection ORS
in Washington State and there's and in
Maine there's stuff going around the
country and there's a lot of progress
that can be made in any ways but not
federally forget it what to be clear if
you want if you want to build a movement
you have to start in cities and states
whether it whether it's a fifteen dollar
minimum wage marriage equality pot
legalization if you want to change a
culture you have to do the hard work of
changing hearts and minds in localities
first okay
is it unseemly for former President
Barack Obama to earn $400,000 for an
upcoming speech to Wall Street yes he's
doing two speeches each for 400k one to
Cantor god I draw I wish he had spent a
month building houses for poor people
with Jimmy Carter we were gonna do
organized variety babies figured he paid
his dues with that personally as well
he's not running for office again I
don't care how much money he makes that
people want to pay in that the free
market value of fairness I don't want a
problem with that and I can get people a
lot of the people who are being
righteously indignant about it are also
people who make lots of different doing
what they do so I don't agree but wait a
second the president the current
president is trying to undo all of his
wall street regulations and then he goes
to Wall Street and takes Twitter isn't
that what sort of cost Hillary the
election are those horrible speeches she
made in the district and Jeff Burton
released the transcript silent released
the criteria no but they did not know
but the the differences are you in the
pocket of right Wall Street and she's
running for ours he's not running for
anything right now and you know I'm
going to now Michelle Obama might be a
difference now she not right nobody
doesn't want I'll have a problem with
this it kind of looks like when he's on
our team were okay with it
no no I don't feel that way I mean leave
if you were running for president I
would have and and in other words if
there was a time lapse and he had done
those speeches and then I do have a
problem with that because then you then
you get into the whole area of conflict
of interest which this administration is
just one big ball you could make
conflict events I of course it is but
you could say that what when he went a
guy is president he's looking ahead to
that $400,000 payday and he's not going
to get it if while he's president he's
going to do something that's going to
piss them off so isn't the best thing to
do take your ten million dollar book
deal can't you live on that well that's
not be a choice it's individual freedom
in our doing whether is we go
thank you there's also the truth is that
the country is being torn apart because
a few people are doing well and most
people aren't right and this is the
canonical example of that it's it's just
such a pure expression of that I'm
surprised I'm really I'm a catalyst I'm
a father probably when I don't know when
America became I covet my neighbor's
success country this is a country where
you could come from nothing and be
something it is not if he is no he is
not going to run for office again he's a
private citizen and someone's willing to
pay him $4,000 of a speech I don't care
if there's low laws are broken
that's fine by me that's America you
know what it's never about getting
nobody hates anybody else's success I
don't know about that a lot of people
there's a lot of class warfare why what
are you saying oh I think a lot of
people hate other people's success oh
you got show business [ __ ] yeah you met
what I'm talking about it very much
everybody we're a great audience you are
a great
[Applause]